ils étaient des centaines ce samedi à la
haye pour protester contre les nouvelles
mesures sanitaires alors que les
autorités néerlandaises avaient assoupli
les restrictions liées aux qu'ovide 19
elles viennent à leur tour d'introduire
le pass sanitaires pour entrer dans les
lieux recevant du public sauf en
terrasse sur twitter le ministre de la
santé s'est félicité de sa mise en place
adieu ou 1,5 m le symbole de toute
limite un grand pas que nous n'aurions
pas pu franchir sans carte d'accès
corona parce que trop de gens n'ont pas
encore été vaccinés c'est la réalité
une mesure loin de faire l'unanimité
toutes générations confondues de
nombreux néerlandais considère qu'il
s'agit d'une entrave à leur liberté
comme vous pouvez le voir sur mon
t-shirt j'ai 80 ans et j'ai décidé il ya
quelques temps qu'il était essentiel que
je vienne à ces manifestations pour
notre liberté
pour récupérer nos libertés que nous
avons perdus sous ce gouvernement
et surtout maintenant avec le qr code
qui est ridicule c'est pourquoi nous
avons manifesté aujourd'hui
manifestations également en france 60
3700 personnes dont sept mille deux
cents à paris ont défilé ce week-end
contre le pass annie terre malgré une
légère baisse de la mobilisation le
mouvement de protestation s'est
poursuivie pour le 11e samedi consécutif
une atteinte à la liberté je veux
pouvoir aller comme avant dans la vie
d'avant un qui ne reviendra jamais je
veux pas être surveillés je veux pas
être la veille du crédit social comme en
chine on a des droits et il faut qu'on
les respecte ici on est tous contre le
pass and i ter n'est pas contre la
vaccination on est juste là pour montrer
aux gens pour montrer au gouvernement
que eux ils s'entêtent mais nous les
suites
cela on et leurs réponses ils ne veulent
pas entendre la rue balard eut fait
encore plus de bruit la rue va continuer
à faire du bruit jusqu'à ce que mc ont
quitté lisait
mis en place au mois d'août dernier
l'application du pass sanitaire en
france devait s'arrêter le 15 novembre
prochain mais un projet de loi pour le
projet sera présenté le 13 octobre en
conseil des ministres